[Music]
did you know that just this year
paleontologists have discovered new
insights into the behavior and
appearance of spinosaurus the
biomechanics of megalodon teeth in the
strangest early life forms of the
cambrian explosion new revelations are
occurring all the time regarding earth's
distant past yet these incredible
findings often go unnoticed by the
general public
so this year i'm taking part in paleo
rewind a breakdown of some of the most
important revelations in the field of
paleontology from the past year all
sorts of other creators you might
already be subscribed to are also
participating in this video i'll kick
the rewind off by covering findings from
the first half of january but be sure to
check out everyone else's entries too in
the final 2021 compilation video that
will be uploaded on edge's channel now
let's get started
beginning in early january 2021 we have
new findings on the potential ecology
and feeding behavior of the famous
theropod spinosaurus the spinosaurus is
a dinosaur that has long gripped popular
culture in its elongated jaws thanks in
part to its appearance in the jurassic
park franchise but the common conception
i grew up with of the spinosaurus as a
bigger heavier t-rex analog isn't quite
accurate indeed the spinosaurus has been
the subject of considerable recent
debate regarding its biology and ecology
as it might have been highly unique from
other carnivorous theropods due to its
semi-aquatic or perhaps highly aquatic
lifestyle a paper published january 7th
by dr david hohn and dr thomas holtz
weighs the likelihood of spinosaurus
being a waiting animal that fed on fish
near the shorelines and in shallow water
or a specialized aquatic pursuit
predator their studies were quite
complex but to simplify based on the
anatomy of the fossils we have and
related ecological data the waiting
model is more supported than the highly
aquatic one still the authors note that
spinosaurus almost certainly fed
primarily from the water and may have
swum which alone might have made it
incredibly distinct from most other
large theropods
our next discovery exposes new
revelations regarding the history of a
highly adapted group of aquatic
predators sharks for hundreds of
millions of years sharks of various
sizes have been patrolling earth's
oceans and throughout the cenozoic an
extinct family known as megatooth sharks
started to trend towards gigantism a
trend that culminated in the well-known
megalodon the largest macro predatory
shark to ever exist this species
exceeded lengths of up to 15 meters or
50 feet and likely weighed more than 50
tons but a mystery has long surrounded
the megalodon regarding the nature of
their teeth
compared to the teeth of earlier
megatooth sharks megalodon teeth
consistently had greater crown width for
reasons that aren't entirely clear
recently dr antonio bael and dr humberto
ferrone ran a series of experiments
testing the biomechanics of earlier
megatooth shark teeth compared to the
megalodon and the results were quite
surprising it seemed stress distribution
patterns were remarkably similar across
all models meaning that the teeth of
megalodons while obviously deadly
weren't any better adapted than the
teeth of other sharks in their family it
seems that megalodon teeth shifted in
shape as a byproduct of their gigantism
instead of a specific evolutionary
advantage still it wouldn't have been
fun to get bitten by one
winding back the clock by half a billion
years we reached the cambrian explosion
a metaphorical eruption in the diversity
of early life forms which as of january
2021 we have new information on you
might already know that the cambrian
explosion gave rise to countless bizarre
life forms many of which seem more like
alien life than something from earth's
past from the surreal opinion which
might have possessed a flexible trunk
that makes it look almost like a living
cartoon to the hallucigenia an animal so
dreamlike its name comes from the word
hallucination it's a fascinating early
milestone in earth's biodiversity in a
recent examination by dr aj shore and dr
r.a wood unveils a new addition to this
pantheon of oddities through the
analysis of some exceptionally
well-preserved fossils researchers were
able to distinguish a life form that
possessed a cup-shaped skeleton with six
radially arranged lobes surrounding what
was likely its mouth a reconstruction of
this life form shows it was a highly
unique form of animal in perhaps a
foundational member of the
lofotrochozoan clade a group that today
includes various types of cephalopods
and mollusks
sometimes seemingly small discoveries in
the realm of paleontology can lead to
major revelations one article from
january 6 shows a curious potential
relationship between herbivorous
dinosaurs and the very plants that they
ate a new examination of fossilized gut
contents by dr george perry suggests
plant seeds remained intact within the
stomachs of plant-eating dinosaurs
cross-referencing this data with the
distances they likely walked it seems
possible that herbivorous dinosaurs
disperse plant seeds far and wide via
their well droppings strange though this
might sound some modern plant munchers
like african bush elephants play a
similar role in the
seed dispersal of certain types of
plants in fact the dispersal of plant
seeds within the bodies of animals is so
frequent in current ecosystems that
plants often modify their fruits and
flowers to appeal more to specific
species and since some dinosaurs could
consume even more plant matter per day
than elephants it's likely they were
highly sought after seed distributors
millions of years ago a strange but
fascinating discovery
and our last article covers a whole new
taxon of marine predator with
specialized teeth unlike those of any
known reptile this new taxon is a member
of the mosasaurids a group of
mid-cretaceous lizards that became
specialized for marine life this
exciting new taxon called xenodens
kalmanchari lived just before the kpg
extinction and stands out from all other
mosasaurids as reported in the article
by dr natalie barde and dr nicholas
longrich this new mosasaurid possessed
teeth that were hooked and formed a
saw-like blade the specialized teeth
suggest a previously unknown hunting
strategy likely involving a cutting
motion to carve pieces out of large prey
or perhaps these unique teeth were used
for scavenging already deceased marine
lifeforms
in either case these teeth are unique
not just among mosasaurids but all
reptiles in general
and those are just some of the major
paleontological revelations of early
january special thanks to edge for
inviting me to be a part of paleo rewind
other channels like mine will be
releasing videos covering other months
in the coming days and i'll add links to
them in the description when they upload
and paleoanalysis is covering the second
half of january so check out their great
video next if you want to go in order
and as always thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this entry into the archive
please lend your support and like
subscribe and hit the notification icon
to stay up to date on all things curious
see you in the next video
[Music]
you